we walk up to him and he's sitting and
Don junior introduces me and he says dad
this is Gabe Ruben he has a great
podcast you know blah blah blah
and Trump looks look that when he's like
you kind of recognize you and I was like
oh well you know I go on Fox I'm on
Tucker Tucker that must be and he turns
to you and he goes man who are you you
were you I'm just standing there who are
you and you go well I'm his husband and
he goes husband hardly did you are
married you two were married and then he
slaps his hands on the table
yeah and he goes he goes I want to stand
up I want to stand up and shake your
hands I think that's great I think
that's Lonnie he's like he's like honey
these two guys are married
he turns music you - you guys are too
good-looking that's a problem too
good-looking I'm going to mention
somebody that you have to mention when
you have conversations on camera in 2020
yeah
President Donald J Trump oh geez so I
was thinking it could be interesting for
us to share with these fine people our
own personal story of meeting the
president because I don't think you've
told this story or have you I've only
told this story I think once publicly
which was on Glenn Beck when I did the
what was it it was Super Tuesday which
now feels like a lifetime ago remember
when there was gonna be an election and
he was asking me something about Trump
and I did tell this story but but
basically outside of Glenn's audience
and and some of our audience nobody's
heard this story right certainly
nobody's heard it from your perspective
so it would not just seem talk about so
we did we did meet the president
yeah so this was I believe on December
22nd of 2019 so did Hubbard a couple
months ago why it was either the 21st or
22nd cuz I know that's the day I was
speaking at this turning point because I
made I mean honestly I don't know why
well cuz I remember I remember thinking
it's the last sort of thing I'm gonna do
for the year I think if these mushroom
supplements that you take in the morning
I do like those mud I think you're right
you know I do you take these like really
good like brain supplements that are
yeah that are like you know faux for
focus and memory I think it works maybe
it would've been ago maybe a December
fans yeah well I remember it was right
before it was right
well basically we were I was giving a
speech and then it was announced like
right the day before or maybe even that
morning the Trump was gonna speak and so
I spoke and then they canceled a bunch
of speakers and then Trump spoke so in
effect I ended up opening for him which
was kind of interesting and after the
event charlie Kirk messaged me and he
said oh do you want to meet the
president said let's do it he they asked
for some info and then we get in a short
line of about 10 people they throw us in
a little booth we meet the president
it's very in and out you want to add
anything for that yeah I mean basically
just I think we were staying in for the
Rob Smith yeah
and I was like very the whole thing
happened so quickly that I didn't know
the present was gonna be there yeah and
we really how's this gonna work and they
took all of our phones and they
literally threw us in this tent with
that we call it a tent but basically
they've like hung for curtains so nobody
could see that he was there and it was
so fast that it was like they moved us
in and by the time you turned to like
take the picture they were turning you
to also exit you out of this room yeah
they seemed live it was like you shake
his hand you had like a moment to say
something to him but it was like you
turn in like they snapped the photo like
while you're moving around and then
you're out and I was like I don't even
know where the camera was and we thought
that that was it
like we met the president we got a photo
who knows if we'll ever see this photo
and thinking that that's it and then we
so we have the photo and then and then
Trump speaks and it was the first time
we had ever heard him speak which was
which was just putting aside whatever
you think about Trump it was just super
interesting to watch the way he works
with the crowd right and he sort of
doing stand-up it was like boys with
stand-ups yeah and he's like in you know
he's off prompter any time going forward
he's going for last feeding his yeah I
know more about windmills than anybody
and he's laughing with them like it's a
joke yeah so but putting all that aside
he speaks and then afterwards we we
bumped into Don junior and he's become a
good buddy of mine and he said would you
like would you and David like to join us
for dinner tonight and I'm wait I'm
blanking on her name can really go she
was like she was like hey like come over
here and she I guess I knew about me
through you and she was like you know
we've we've got a table for the four of
us you know can you can you join us are
you free and I was like sure okay yeah
where do you want to go and she's like
oh Mar Lago and I have to admit like you
know I'm not as plugged into all this
stuff and that's
that's intentional but I'm not as
plugged into all this stuff obviously
I've heard of Mar Lago but I do not know
at this point what mar-a-lago is yeah I
don't know if it's a hotel I don't know
if it's a restaurant I don't know if
it's a golf course I come to learn it's
basically it's like all of that yeah but
I really didn't know what it was so when
she said it was at mar-a-lago I was like
oh so it is a restaurant but that just
shows you how how much I don't know
about right that you know part of trumps
world so fortunately we had suits
because we were supposed to go that
night to an event that Ben Shapiro we're
not headlining and we were supposed to
be in season I think sorry Ben we we
left yet to go see the president we go
to Mara Lago there's like like an
absolute insane security situation and
they have to like drive us around a
small miles around yeah it's like crazy
to get in there we get in there we're
like basically almost strip searched
before thrown on the back of a golf cart
yeah like they really am oh it's the
president I know and then as you
described it it's sort of like the
Playboy Mansion but like doused in gold
and hairspray it didn't feel cheesy at
all and actually nobody no kind of
classy or old-school or something and we
go in and there's a main dining room and
I'd say there were probably about 50
people in the main dining room and
Candace Owens was there and a couple
other people that we sort of knew and we
were sort of whisked into the side room
which is I guess the more exclusive room
where there's maybe 20 people right and
our table is right in the middle just an
extra layer of secret services to get
into that room right and it made they
make sure no phones no pictures blah
blah blah our tables like literally in
the center of the room so the four of us
have a nice dinner and sitting next to
us you know one table over is President
Trump and Melania and Rudy Giuliani and
they have two other two or three other
people there and we have a great dinner
we had a great time right like totally
fun and Don doesn't drink but and when
some one funny thing was happening but
somehow the way we were sitting I kept
drinking your your wine so basically I
had like cuz you're a lefty which oh
that's what it was see what I did here
actually today this isn't a real shoot
yeah I let you have your water on your
left side normally I make the water on
that side and then people say I was over
there they say Allah stole my lefty
creds
look at that anyway then at the end of
the meal junior says he actually gonna
take some crazy
Junior says hey do you want to meet my
dad I was like
you know let's meet your dad so we go up
to him and and remember this is like two
or three days after impeachment had just
been announced which feels like another
lifetime ago at this point and everyone
every story was about Trump is freaking
out you're closing in he's a paranoid
lunatic the guy sitting there he had no
tie on he looked totally relaxed his
hair was a little more disheveled than
usual he was having a ball we were
laughs if you were living on the moon ya
didn't know who Donald Trump was and you
know who the president United States was
and all of a sudden you found yourself
in this room and they said to you the
President of the United States is in
this room who do you think it is I
guarantee you you would never think it
was him right this guy was sitting there
pretty quiet yeah for the most of dinner
just listening to other people listening
to his wife speak mostly actually and
was I was expecting this like loud
bombastic blowhard sorta I was like not
nothing even against him it's just I
think everyone can agree like he's you
would think he's this it would be the
center of attention sucking a lot of the
energy out of the room the exact
opposite yeah it was the reverse so so
we walk up to him and he's sitting and
Don junior introduces me and he says dad
this is Dave Rubin he has a great
podcast you know blah blah blah and
Trump looks look that when he's like you
kind of recognize you and I was like oh
well you know I go on Fox I'm on Tucker
Tucker that must be and he turns to you
and he goes man who are you
you were you I'm just standing there
yeah who are you and you go well I'm his
husband and he goes husband how did you
are married you two were married and
then he slaps his hands on the table
yeah and he goes he goes I want to stand
up I want to stand up and shake your
hands I think that's great I think
that's Jerry's money he's like he's like
honey these two guys are married then he
turns music your - you guys are too
good-looking that's a problem you're too
good-looking
if I gotta shake your hand that's
fantastic that's fantastic and then he
says he goes you know I don't give a
[ __ ] he goes and I don't think anybody
else does either and it in a very Trump
way and also I don't think anybody has
for 20 years no one's giving a [ __ ] for
20 years yeah and I really at that point
I was like oh he thinks that I think
he's probably a homophobe because I'm
gay and that's right and told by the
media but I mean that moment like I I
mean I knew already he wasn't a
homophobe so I'm not thinking that but I
realized how much does that suck for him
to have to preface that after he needs a
gay couple to say you know like
you know I don't care right like we're
cool right um and then Melania was
making eyes at you across she was like
talking her friendly they kept pointing
at me so you and Chum started talking
about playing tulsi gabbard in a couple
other yeah well then Trump jr. got kind
of pulled away for a second so then I'm
there with Trump for like five minutes
and a prowling about my crazy theories
about my yeah and he was totally fun and
interesting in any way so then you were
and also then I went over to Milani and
I was like and she looks up and she was
like how old are you in a vein like
you're very you know thick accent how
old are you and I realize what happened
was her and her friend were trying to
figure out how old I was they thought I
was too young to be that was the hell do
you think I am and she was like 20 and I
was like no I'm 31 and she was like all
you have beautiful skin and so I was
like wow thanks and I look so do you
and then I in a net you know that we
talked for a while actually about the
friend that she was with I think had
given money to Hillary's campaign and it
was just so interesting that people out
at this table
yeah and then what actually the most
interesting part was which we discovered
when we got into the car to leave I said
to you what what was what's standing out
in your mind and we and it was exactly
what I saw which was I said to Trump
something about Bloomberg and why I
thought he was getting into the race and
Trump turns to Melania they're both
sitting we're so we're standing you're
standing across my day but I'm standing
on this side and he puts his hand on her
arm and he says honey what do you think
about this and then he has me repeat my
my bamberg theory and she was like oh
that's really interesting that's really
interesting but what but what was really
interesting about it was that he turned
to her in the way he put his hand on her
and the way she responded and honey what
do you think about this like they
actually love you yeah there it was so
interesting to me because I was like why
haven't I seen this like it was very
clear they in that room they did have to
put on a show for anybody and I was like
these two people definitely like each
other like a lot like right mom he's gut
reaction when I said something
interesting to him was let me turn to my
wife and see what's worse yeah yeah no
it's very interesting and that is to
when we got in the car after that's what
I said what was the thing that stood out
isn't that exactly what you said but
it's just funny because you know I don't
believe a lot of the lies about him but
that with my own eyes I've seen it you
see everyone's seen those like famous
pictures or videos where she's a little
bit
you know skittish or standoffish from
him and I was like I don't know I guess
I don't it's interesting
[Music]
you